من جانبه قال موقع اوريبار العسكري روسيا
القوات الروسيه صدت هجمات جديده للقوات
الاوكرانيه قرب بلده كليشيفكا جنوب مدينه
باخاموت ونشرت قوات دونياتسكا المواليه
لروسيا صورا لقصف اهداف عسكريه اوكرانيا
كما توصلت المعارك في محاور كوبيانس
بمقاطعه خركيف ومارينكا
وافديفكاضافه الى محاور اريخوف بمقاطعه
بدورها افادت سلطات المواليه لروسيا بصد
محاولتين اوكرانيتين لعبور نهر دنيبر الى
الضفه اليسرى الخاضعه للسيطره الروسيه
واضافت ان 46 عسكريا اوكرانيا قتلوا كما
تم تدمير سبعه قوارب عسكريه خلال صد
محاوله العبور الاوكرانيه للنهر ميدانيه
ايضا بثت وكاله ريانوفوستي الروسيه صورا
قالت فانها لقصف مدفعي استهدف حشدا من
القوات الاوكرانيه في مدينه فاسيليفكا
بمقاطعه زامبورجيا جنوبيه اوكرانيا دون
ذكر مزيد من التفاصيل
ما اخر التطورات الميدانيه وهون هناك رد
فعل على هذا الاتهام للقوات الاوكرانيه
باستخدام الذخائر العنقوديه
في الواقع بالنسبه لذخائر العقوديه كانت
كياف دائما ما تتهم القوات الروسيه بانها
قامت باستخدام هذه القذائف والقنابل
العنقوديه منذ بدايه الحرب العام الماضي
كنت اتواجد في خاركاف وحينها اعلنت
السلطات الاوكرانيه بان القوات الروسيه
استخدمت القنابل العنقوديه في خاركاب
اثناء حصالها لتلك المدينه وايضا توسع
الامر الى مناطق اخرى اما بالنسبه
للاتهامات الروسيه اليوم
بانها استخدمت القنابل العنقوديه فلم يصدر
اي تاكيد من القوات الاوكرانيه سواء
باستخدام هذه القنابل في مناطق عسكريه او
بعدم استخدامها ولكن ما يمكن الحديث عنه
حاليا بان هنالك وثمه التغير في التكتيكات
التي تعتمدها القوات الاوكرانيه خلال
المعارك وقد لاحظنا هذا الامر خلال الايام
القليله الماضيه بعدما كانت القوات
الاوكرانيه تدفع بارتال من جنودها
والمدرعات في محاوله منها لاختراق خطوط
الجبهه على اكثر من محور س كان الامر على
مستوى دونيتش او في خرسون او حتى
ذابولوجيا من الواضح انه خلال الايام
الماضيه التكتيك اختلف واصبحت القوات
الاوكرانيه تعتمد بشكل رئيسي على القصف
المدفعي والقصف بالصواريخ والمسيارات وذلك
لان الالتحام المباشر مع القوات الروسيه
كبد القوات الاوكرانيه خسائر كبيره وصفتها
الصحافه الغربيه وتحديدا نقلا عن بعض
المسؤولين الغربيين كما نقلت صحيفه
بالامس بانها خسرت القوات الاوكرانيه اكثر
من 20% من القوات العسكريه وتحديدا
المدرعات التي كانت قد حصلت عليها من
الدول الغربيه وبالتالي انطلاقا من هذه
الخسائر التي تكبدتها على مستوى المدرعات
والعربات وعربات الجند خلال الاسابيع
السته من تاريخ انطلاق العمليه العسكريه
والهجوم المضاد من الواضح ان الان تغير
التكتيك العسكري الذي تتبعها هذه القوات
وهذا ما رصد سواء من خلال استخدام
المسيرات في مهاجمه شبه جزيره القرم او
حتى في امطار كافه المواقع العسكريه
الروسيه بالقذائف والصواريخ على طول
الجبهه هذا الامر لم يعد حكرا على مستوى
جبهه واحده ولكن يمكن ان نرصده انطلاقا من
مقاطعه خركاب وتحديدا في كوبيانك مرورا
بلمان
وباخموند وغيرها من المناطق تحديدا ايضا
في الدركه ومارينكا القوات الاوكرانيه
تقوم الان باستخدام المدفعيه مدفعيات التي
كانت قد حصلت عليها من الدول الغربيه
وتحديدا من واشنطن وهي في محاوله منها
لدفع الخطوط الاماميه للقوات الخطوط
الاماميه للقوات الروسيه في محاوله
مستقبليه لمحاوله لاحداث صغره ما يمكن ان
نفاذ منها على مستوى جبهه باخموت او غيرها
من الجبهات بطبيعه الحال القوات
الاوكرانيه وعلى لسان قائدها العام
قال يوم امس بان قواته تفت الى امداد
بالذخائر هو اشاره بان عدم انتظام الامداد
بالذخائر هو ما يحول دون احداث هذه القوات
فارقا على مستوى التقدم الميداني مضيفا
بان التحصينات التي اقامتها روسيا الالغام
التي زرعتها طيله الاسابيع والاشهر
الماضيه حول مواقعها بانتظار الهجوم
المضاد ايضا اثرت بشكل كبير على حركه
المدرعات والدبابات التي حصلت عليها
اوكرانيا وبالتالي اذا ما اضيف كل هذا
الامر الى ما كانت قد تحدثت عنه القياده
الاوكرانيه عن فقدانها لمنظومه
الطائرات الحربيه التي تمكن من توفير مظله
للعمليات العسكريه يمكن القول ان ضمن كل
هذه المعطيات من الواضح بان الهجوم تغير
تكتيكه الذي تقوم به القوات الاوكرانيه
وباتت تعتمد اكثر على قصف المدفعي
والصاروخي بعيد المدى بعيد ومتوسط المدى
في محاوله كامل القوات الروسيه ومن بعدها
التقدم مجددا ميد انيا والالتحام مع
القوات الروسيه على الارض